mâcon exactement ce que j'ai voulu dire
il est le grand vide il est là
si vous voulez hein c'est un adolescent
qui se cherche on a l'impression d'un
type qui n'est pas fini on a
l'impression de quelqu'un qui n'a pas en
fait les idées claires sur rien qui un
jour va dire l'otan est en état de mort
cérébrale et puis le lendemain et puis
le lendemain va faire des mamours
hommage américains qui l'ont humilié qui
nous ont humiliés ce type n'est pas fini
ce type dit tout et le contraire de tout
donc moi je dis oui emmanuel macron
c'est le vide et c'est d'un adolescent
qui n'est pas fini alors il a dit ça et
là il n'a pas été il n'a pas été il a
encore ajouté des choses pour le
candidat à la présidentielle tout ce
qu'il dit ce n'est pas des insultes
regarde si ces mots vous étés vous aider
à dresser est ce que vous les trouverez
injurieux franchement injurieux non
violent oui injurieux non violent nuit
je le traite pas moi de racines de
fascistes de nazis nommé la bonne foi de
vous
alors bruno attendez on s'inquiète pour
un mot fin de race on traite le
président de type on le traite de grand
vide sidéral c'est moins la grand mère
disait les mauvais chiens il aboie plus
fort qui mordent bas on l'a vu il à
boire alors il aboie saveurs avec
zemmour comme un chien pas du tout et
bien c'est intéressant c'est intéressant
ce qu'ont à dire parce que justement
quand on attaque monsieur zemmour là bas
qu'est ce qu'on apprend doit être polis
et on doit boire le thé là la différence
est le monsieur zemmour avec ce type de
violence aura en ce qui me concerne non
pas de la bienveillance mais de la
résistance et il était normal que il n'a
pas traité de raciste de fascistes
d'extrémistes les méninges c'est normal
mais il attendait regard des clichés
mais que saab le vent récolte la tempête
attendant regardez bien ces quelques
thèmes donnés dans les changes politique
quand eric zemmour dit emmanuel macron
c'est le vide c'est le vide politique
ses idées quand eric zemmour dit
emmanuel macron n'est pas fini aussant
fini ça pendant m'attendais
ce
n'est pas fini dans un bain non
évidemment c'est considéré comme une
insulte et pas finir non si moi je vous
disais tiens c'est pour ça qu'on dit fin
de race parce que vous n'êtes pas finir
fin de race c'est très différent ah ben
c'est que c'est quoi prendre à témoin
moi je ne sais pas bien ce que ça veut
dire
d'une ancienne génération dans l'ancien
da royauté des aristos voilà qui était
un peu qu'on sent bien et que la race
ces services
sont revenus mais galère à 7 1
exactement donc c'est quand même assez
c'est violent c'est extrêmement violent
et c'est lorsque vous et surtout quand
on veut être président de la république
non mais un bar à la limite 1 on est un
peu bourré 11e' des conneries et on le
fait mais quand on veut être président
de la république on se présence de
monsieur bourdin qui ont pu c'est un
malin sait faire parler comme un autre
que je connais et bien derrière on peut
pas se permettre ça là il s'est
disqualifié pour moi il est parti en
diable à l'om j'ai pas le coach ça mais
c'est vrai qu'elle est ce qu'on peut
pour être violent comme ça que président
et bien sûr que non qu'on peut pas dire
en plus ya pas de violence en plus sur
la séquence précédente
pas besoin de kidnapper un nom je pense
qu'un bon petit coup de fil il pleure il
peut avoir il peut avoir le dialogue
avec le président il a jamais alors ça
lui plaira peut-être parce qu'il
entendra mais pas besoin de le kidnapper
passer le mot kidnappé qui a gêné c'est
le mot qui leur est il assez travaillé
en ce moment voilà c'est ça c'est ça qui
dérange mais oui il faut dire la vérité
quand même il ya beaucoup de français
qui prononce ce genre de phrase dans la
vie tous les jours et vous parlez des
bars tout à l'heure je pense que c'est
le fond de commerce d'eric zemmour c'est
que c'est un candidat qui habille et
qu'un costume cravate et qui est
derrière public mais qui parle comme
n'importe qui au pmu du coin c'est pour
ça que les gens se reconnaissent mais
c'est pour ça que ça ne me choque pas sa
promesse et d'être sans filtre d'être
cash il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
reconnaissent dans ce qu'il dit
désolé guillaume et il ya tu peux pas
demander à tes enfants de respecter
leurs professeurs si les parents ne
respecte pas le président de la
république ils sont le respect il à tous
les niveaux à tous les étages donc forêt
je respecte le protocole tournefeuille
ne pas respecter un ancien président
mais président
françois hollande ce qui nous regarde
oui je suis pas du tout d'accord avec
jean michel de vous rappeler quand même
que le délit d' offense au président
n'existe plus où la loi dire ce qu'on
veut du président le président lui même
est irresponsable devant ces axes et un
grand privilège donc on a le droit de
l'attaquer si non alors lui il fait ce
qu'il veut et plus personne n'a le droit
de parler de lui moi je trouve que ça
reste correct c'est à l'antenne c'est
comme trump a fait dans la campagne
contre joe biden qui d'ailleurs avait
fini par répliquer en traitant de clown
donc je ne sais pas ce que va faire
emmanuel macron c'est compliqué value
région de feu sur un monde sans voiture
et moi pour moi c'est viril martin la
campagne il répondra peut-être parce que
sinon un mot beaucoup plus subtil déjà
pour commencer puis deuxièmement
deuxièmement le on peut si on part
effectivement je suis assez d'accord
avec l'idée de dire si on veut donner
des modèles parce que monsieur zemmour
nous assomme avec les modèles d'une
france un ouh c'était travail famille
patrie et c'est plus formidable que le
reste si on veut jouer sur des modèles
on peut pas montrer des modèles de
violence dans le discours politique
parce que ça va finir en pugilat
n'importe quel débat on va devenir par
sortie c'est un discours de campagne at
one vous y étiez peut-être aux journées
parlementaires de l ère où m à avignon
qu'il assure jean marc borello monsieur
véran qui ont dit eric zemmour est un
virus eric zemmour c'est la peste brune
et caetera et c'est donc j'imagine
qu'une opinion c'est comme vous c'est un
avant alors ça c'était chaud opinion on
est d'accord j'adorais une quand eric
zemmour quand les débris nous vas-y de
manuel macron que sa pensée n'est pas
fini non là on est un organisme a filmé
la famille il n'est pas fini il n'est
pas finie au sénat devient c'est qu'il
essaye de dire c'est emmanuel macron ces
deux en même temps vous savez c'est
l'enfant de 15 ans qui arrive pas à
choisir alors il est pour ça et en même
temps il est pour ca est en fait et en
fait c'est ça alors demain départ examen
là ce soir on n'est pas là dessus on est
deux immo et sur la forme les neuf
entrées bout de champ labouré
l'eau a dit d'eric zemmour que c'était
la peste brune un virus etc donc si vous
voulez il n'est pas prévu qu'il n'est
pas candidat à la présidence
d'énormités d'hommes différentes selon
qui on est bah non ah ben ça n'est pas
moi qui le dit à l'écouté d'hommes doit
écouter le discours riggs les hôtels 10
g le monsieur zemmour n'en écoute estime
qu'effectivement les bons français les
mauvais français les bons musulmans les
mauvais musulmans alors dans la main
d'un côté il en remet une beigne de
l'autre et vous attendez vous
caricaturez encore mais je n'avais
jamais france ce mettez vous à vous
habituer parce que watchmen caricaturer